women in america
are
increasingly
miserable
this is not a
wonderful paradise for women
women
don't actually have it all that great in
america these days and it's getting
worse and worse since second wave
feminism over the past 50 or so years
as
can be measured by social scientists
women's happiness has declined
both in absolute terms and relative to
the happiness of men
they're getting more and more and more
miserable
today because of the transgender
movement women are losing their ability
to
use their own bathrooms
women are
losing the ability to compete on their
own sports teams women are all the
awards now are going to men who are
pretending to be women
what is the great freedom of women in
america
what a lot of
liberals would tell you
is that women have it so great in
america because they have the right
to
to do porn they have the right to go on
onlyfans.com and sell their bodies like
they are just flesh
and make some money prostituting
themselves that's one of the women in
iran don't have that right but in so
that's why it's wrong for iran to be on
the u.n women's council but it's good
for america too women in america they
don't have to deal with the patriarchy
of one man loving them for their entire
lives and having a stable marriage and a
stable
building block of society no no women in
america haven't much better they
get to be used by men for decades until
they're no longer as physically
attractive and then they get to be
discarded and they get to spend the rest
of their lives alone working in the
widget factory
isn't that isn't that so great
wow wow we need to give lectures to
everybody hmm maybe not maybe actually
i can't believe i'm saying this but
maybe some of the feminists
who are critical of
things like our hookup culture some of
the feminists who are critical of some
of the excesses of second wave feminism
maybe some of the conservatives
who have been critical of this whole
project maybe they have a point
and maybe
maybe we're actually not doing such a
great job of taking care of women we're
the libs and a number of republicans are
trying to draft women into combat right
now
this is a major political fight that
josh hawley probably stopped but it's
going to come back up again
we're we're so great to women in america
that we are going to send them to be
killed by jihadis in the middle east
that's how great we are um i don't think
so maybe there's a good opportunity
for introspection i don't know
you're seeing this right now on jeopardy
uh dude just became
the woman with the highest overall
winnings
in jeopardy history
women in america are actually put upon
enough now that they can't even win the
women's awards jeopardy contestant
thomas schneider who now goes by a
woman's name and dresses like a woman
and says that he is a woman
he has just earned more money than any
female competitor in jeopardy history
and larissa kelly who previously held
the distinction as the woman with the
highest all-time winnings
just congratulated
thomas schneider and said well it was
fun to hold a jeopardy record for a few
years but it's been even more fun to
watch
jeopardy set new standards for
excellence on the show and off
congratulations to amy that's the name
that this man is going by on becoming
the woman with the highest overall
earnings in the show's history
this is this is probably the most
painful part
for women of this new transgenderist
regime
is they have to pretend that this is
great
do you remember when the dude the giant
dude on the u-pen women's swimming team
beat all the women's records and then
the women would privately say to
journalists off the record anonymously
they would say you're not off the record
but but on background i suppose and
anonymously they would say
this is terrible we hate this but we've
all got to applaud because we'll be
called haters
so this woman has to say oh it's great
that the men are taking all the women's
stuff
i i'm really happy about that they're
setting new standards of excellence the
new standard of excellence according to
feminism and transgenderism
is men
that's the that's the new standard of
excellence
and conservatives
i think are not really serious about
stopping this
right conservatives
conservatives still do things like
they'll they'll call men who pretend to
be women they will call them by his he's
a biological male
this person
amy they'll use the women's name they'll
say amy schneider on jeopardy he
this person they often don't even use
the pronouns is a biological male
as though there were any other kind of
male
it's the he's a biological male but he's
a spiritual female he's a biological
male but he's a psychologist it's just a
dude and when you when you add the
modifier biological to male you are
granting the premise that there are
different types of male and female and
that some male are kind of they can also
be female or no
i don't think conservatives
have the hutzpah to stop this
because in order to stop this stuff
it's not enough to repudiate only the
weird sex aspect of the fact that
obviously men are not women and women
are not men and they can't become one
another
you also have to repudiate
individualism
you also have to repudiate the excesses
of 20th century libertarianism
you also have to repudiate the idea that
well anthony kennedy said this in the
planned parenthood be casey decision
that man has the right to create his own
concept of existence you also have to
repudiate the idea that we can do
whatever we want to do so long as it
doesn't hurt other people which is a
dubious concept to begin with because
when you have a society doing all sorts
of terrible things that is going to
affect other people because we live in a
society together because man is the
political and social animal and
politics in general is just what we all
do together so yeah you're gonna have to
repudiate that are you willing to are
you willing to say no you can't mutilate
yourself and get the surgery no you
can't pretend to be a woman even in the
confines of your own home you can't
because that is neces if you're a woman
in your own home you're a woman in
public and we're all gonna have to
acknowledge that
live and let live you do you you you do
you all do me doesn't work in a society
it just leads to social breakdown and it
leads to social breakdown just as surely
when the conservatives do it as when the
libs do it and we're in this moment now
where we're seeing massive upheavals of
our way of viewing ourselves and our
relationship to our government and the
way society functions and we're saying
that the covid
the kovid tyranny has been really at the
forefront of that this is a great time
to ask ourselves this question are we
going to just keep going along in the
same process of failure that we've been
keeping up for years and years and years
or is it a new year is it a new year and
a new us and a new opportunity to chart
a course for what we want our country to
look like i'm glad you like that clip
i'm glad that in this new year
still christmas and this wonderful
christmas season you like that clip
go check out the whole show by ringing
the bell subscribing heading on over to
your favorite audio podcast platform
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcasts type
in the michael noll show it's going
gonna take two seconds subscribe that's
a christmas present to yourself
leave a five star review maybe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you